hi everyone my name is kadir den and
today i'm extremely happy to talk about
the most recent project we finished in
this project we tried to design and
manufacture a multi-armed pension
monster card system
so the pendulum on the card system has
long been studied in different research
fields including machine learning
dynamical system system identification
and controls
so in this project we try to detail the
design and manufacturing process of
building such a multi-armed patrol
monster card system so that it can be a
really good useful reference guide for
anyone who is interested building their
own
and moreover we generated an open access
data set from the real experimental
system so that people can use those data
set to test out their algorithms for
example machine learning algorithms or
system identification algorithms if
you're interested please feel free to
check it out using the links below and
all the data set design files and code
are freely available onto github
so in short our system has four major
components servo drive linear motor
real-time system and also the pendulum
arm what the servo drive is doing is
basically providing electrical energy to
our actuator in this case the linear
motor
and the linear motor is responsible for
moving back and forth and while it's
moving it's going to perturb the motion
of the pendulum arm and that's basically
how we control it and there's no motor
installed in the pendulum arm the only
control we have is moving the pendulum
card that's why our system is under
actuated
as for the real-time system it is
responsible for gathering sensor
information and also executing the
user's control law
and in order to achieve a robust control
we have to perform a closed loop control
that's why you can see the closed loop
control we implemented in this figure
at each time step the real-time system
is going to gather sensor information
from the linear system and a linear
motor and also the pendulum arm and it
will determine how we should move the
linear motor at what kind of desired
speed according to the user's control
law it will then send that desired speed
information using an analog signal to
the servo drive and the servo driver
compares the current speed of the linear
motor and also the desired speed of the
linear motor to determine whether we
should increase its velocity or decrease
its velocity
so basically that's the entire control
algorithm or the control diagram we're
using in the system
and now i want to talk about some design
details and the first thing i'll walk
through is the pendulum arm
so the pendulum arm we used is actually
a triple pendulum arm but it is easily
detachable so for example you can take
off one of the arm to make it as double
pendulum will take out one more arm to
make it a single pendulum and moreover
it has a really high accuracy sensor
installed with 10 000 cpr
and with this really high accuracy
sensors we can detect really tiny
movement of the pendulum arm down to
0.009 degrees which is super awesome
and when it comes to the linear motor
its maximum speed is 5 meters per second
and it has a really high accuracy as
well down to 1 micrometer
resolution so it is super awesome as
well
and
when it comes to the pendulum art cart
uh it is trying to basically attach the
pendulum arm and the linear motor
together and as you can see here we have
additional sensor encoder sensor
attached to the
bearing housing so that it can
detect the rotational angle of the first
pendulum arm and when we put everything
together and assemble them into a system
frame we can finally have a benchmark
system for learning chaos and control
as an example i'm just going to show you
how we use
this experiment experimental system to
achieve the stabilization of the double
pendulum
to do so you have to first generate the
non-linear model of the double pendulum
and then linearize it around its
equilibrium point and next you have to
use some controller in this case we're
using lqr to stabilize your pendulum and
as you can see even if you poke it
around it is still stable so which is
really interesting and i really like
this video because it's so satisfying uh
and i really like this video a lot
okay
besides some controls experiment we can
also do some system identification
experiment as well and that's why we
have some open access data set and we
even have some high-speed motion camera
capture data set as well so if you're
interested definitely check it out and
if you want to have some custom-made
data set please feel free to email us
and we can generate some some some data
set for you
and after we finish our experiment and
building this experimental system right
we start to realize one problem even
though we made our system open access
and made our design file freely
available it still takes time and effort
to build and maintain such a complicated
system
that's why we start to think about the
idea of cloud experiment so for example
if you're some remote user right you can
probably just upload your controller to
the cloud and we can validate whether
your controller works or not if it does
we can employ it to the
real-time system
and we're going to run it basically on
our experimental system and generate a
bunch of data set and gather an
experimental report and send it back to
you and if your code doesn't work we can
also send you a debug report so that you
can revise your code and by using this
cloud experimental idea the user do not
have to worry about building and
maintaining an experimental system
anymore you just have to use it using
the cloud and we believe this idea is
going to
make our system more widely available to
many users and that's why we're really
interested in this idea and we would
like to implement it in the future as
our future research goal
so in short in this project uh we
designed and manufactured a multi-arm
passion on the card system we also
generated an open access data set and as
our future research goal we want to
tackle the problem of cloud experiment
to make our system more widely available
with that i would like to thank my
collaborators and our funding agency for
making this research possible and thank
all my audience for listening thank you
all and see you next time